hi wir sind wieder für euch ZDF heute
live ganz herzlich willkommen bei uns im
Stream schön dass ihr bei uns seid es
ist offiziell der Salat hat gewonnen
oder wie ist das britische
Boulevardmagazin Daily Star formuliert
dieser Salat hat List Trust überlebt
falls ihr euch jetzt fragt welcher Salat
ich zeige ihn euch es geht um diesen
Salat denn das britische
Boulevardmagazin Daily Star das hat in
den vergangenen Tagen wegen dieser
ganzen Chaostage in Großbritannien
diesen Livestream hier gestartet und die
Wette aufgestellt dass ein Eisbergsalat
in den vergangenen Tagen sich länger
halten wird als Liz trust in ihrer
Funktion als Premierministerin die
Briten nehmen es hier mit Humor in den
Kommentaren und der Daily Star hat seine
Wette gewonnen denn Trust hat heute
Nachmittag nach nur 45 Tagen im Amt
ihren Rücktritt angekündigt innerhalb
einer Woche soll ein Nachfolger oder
eine Nachfolgerin gefunden sein das hat
sie angekündigt damit wäre dann Trust so
oder so die Regierungschefin mit der
kürzesten Amtszeit in der britischen
Geschichte und bevor wir das Analysieren
hier noch mal ihr komplettes Statement
von heute Nachmittag
ich trat mein Amt in einer Zeit großer
wirtschaftlicher und internationaler
Instabilität an Familien und Unternehmen
waren besorgt wie sie ihre Rechnungen
bezahlen sollten Putins illegaler Krieg
in der Ukraine bedroht die Sicherheit
unseres gesamten Kontinents
und unser Land wird schon zu lange durch
ein geringes Wirtschaftswachstum
gebremst
ich wurde von der konservativen Partei
mit dem Auftrag gewählt dies zu ändern
wir haben bei den Energierechnungen und
bei der Senkung der Sozialversicherung
gehandelt und wir hatten eine Vision für
eine Wirtschaft mit niedrigen Steuern
und hohem Wachstum die die Freiheiten
des brexit nutzen würde
ich erkenne jedoch an dass ich
angesichts dieser Situation dass Mandat
mit dem ich von der konservativen Partei
gewählt wurde nicht erfüllen kann
ich habe daher mit seiner Majestät dem
König gesprochen um ihm mitzuteilen dass
ich als Vorsitzende der konservativen
Partei zurücktrete
heute morgen habe ich mich mit dem
Vorsitzenden des 1922 Komitee the Graham
Brady getroffen wir sind übereingekommen
dass innerhalb der nächsten Woche eine
Wahl des Parteivorsitzenden stattfinden
wird dies wird sicherstellen dass wir
unsere finanzpolitischen Pläne umsetzen
und die wirtschaftliche Stabilität und
die nationale Sicherheit unseres Landes
aufrechterhalten können ich werde so
lange Premierministerin bleiben bis ein
Nachfolger gewählt worden ist ich danke
Ihnen
und damit rüber zu Andreas Stamm in
London Andreas schönen guten Abend
erstmal hier bei ZDF heute live wir
haben gerade das Statement von List
Trust gesehen was hat heute das Fass zum
Überlaufen gebracht dass sie
zurückgetreten ist
ja es waren sicherlich die Ereignisse
des gestrigen Abends da kam es zur
Handgreiflichkeiten im Parlament nachdem
eigentlich die Regierung nicht klar
gesagt hat ob eine Abstimmung jetzt eine
Vertrauensabstimmung in die Regierung
ist es ging um das Thema Fracking das
spielt auch mittlerweile gar keine Rolle
mehr aber man versuchte eben Abgeordnete
der Konservativen zu zwingen für Ja zu
stimmen die eigentlich Nein stimmen
wollten es war einfach ein derartiges
Chaos und sowas hat man den britischen
Parlament noch nie gesehen und das hat
viele Parlamentarier der konservativen
auch viele in der Bevölkerung der hat
aufgeschreckt ist ich habe noch nie so
viel Schimpfwörter gehört an einem Abend
im Fernsehen und im Internet gesehen
das war dann einfach einer zu viel denn
man wollte listras war schon erledigt
ihre Beliebtheitswerte sind so
unterirdisch das war überhaupt keine
Frage aber man wollte noch ein wenig mit
ihr ja durch die Gegend hinken um den
Prozess besser abstimmen zu können aber
es war einfach zu viel und dann sind die
parteigranten heute morgen eben hier
hinter mir Antenne Downing Street
aufgetreten und haben das klar gemacht
das war es du musst gehen ja und ja
dieser Bitte
dringend notwendigen bitte ist sie dann
gefolgt dieses Chaos was du ansprichst
Andreas das werden wir gleich im
weiteren Verlauf auch mit dir besprechen
und auch über die Gründe des Rücktritts
werden wir noch mal sprechen mit dem
britischen Labour-Politiker Ben Bradshaw
von der Opposition die fordern ja jetzt
schon Neuwahlen da werden wir ihn zu
befragen und dann hinten raus geben wir
auch noch mal ein zeitgeschichtlichen
Kontext mit dem bekannten Politologen
und britischen Zeithistoriker Anthony
glies stellt gerne eure Fragen an alle
unsere Gesprächspartner entweder direkt
in die Chats oder per Mailadresse wird
eingeblendet ZDF heute - live
@zdf.de bevor wir das machen Yasin
herlein fast uns jetzt noch mal diese
denkwürdigen Stunden da heute aus
Großbritannien aus dem britischen
Unterhaus auch zusammen
es ist zumeist ein schlechtes Zeichen
wenn dieses Pult vor Nummer 10 Downing
Street aufgebaut wird dann wird
wichtiges verkündet in diesem
turbulenten Zeiten meistens Rücktritte
der von distress war nur eine Frage der
Zeit gewesen
wir hatten die Vision für eine
Wirtschaft mit niedrigen Steuern und
hohem Wachstum mit der wir die Vorteile
des brexit nutzen wollten ich habe
angesichts der bestehenden Situation
aber eingesehen dass ich den Auftrag mit
dem ich von der konservativen Partei
gewählt wurde nicht erfüllen kann
jene Partei die immer mehr im Chaos
versinkt bei einer Abstimmung am
gestrigen Abend war es zu tumultartigen
Szenen gekommen als konservative
Abgeordnete angeblich mit physischer
Gewalt dazu gezwungen wurden für die
Regierungspolitik zu rotieren
das ist Chaos eine Schande was hier
passiert unglaublich entsetzlich ich
sollte das nicht sagen aber ich hoffe
dass alle die geholfen haben dass Trust
premier wird dass es sich für Sie
gelohnt hat einmal Minister einmal
wichtig zu sein am Kabinettstisch Platz
zu nehmen denn der Schaden den sie
unserer Partei zugefügt haben ist
ungemein
dabei saß gestern zunächst noch danach
aus als wenn sich Trust noch ein wenig
würde halten können bei der aktuellen
Fragestunde im Parlament schlug sie sich
einigermaßen achtbar dann aber wurde
bekannt dass die amtierende
Innenministerin ihren Hut nehmen musste
schon das zweite hochrangige
Kabinettsmitglied nach Finanzminister
quasiquateng
der hatte für jene Politik der
Steuersenkungen vor allem für Reiche
verantwortlich gezeichnet die von den
Finanzmärkten abgelehnt wurde das Pfund
Abstürzen ließ und inzwischen wieder
zurückgenommen ist mit all dem Messe
jetzt Schluss sein fordert die
Opposition das kann so nicht weitergehen
Großbritannien verdient besseres
Großbritannien kann das Chaos der
konservativen nicht mehr länger ertragen
wir brauchen Neuwahlen und zwar jetzt
doch die Konservativen wollen das wieder
einmal intern regeln bis Ende nächster
Woche
Andreas da haben wir das Chaos gesehen
was du auch gerade schon beschrieben
hast und eben diesen Ausblick dass die
Tories das wieder internen klären wollen
einen Name der bei der Nachfolge auch
wieder auftaucht es ist tatsächlich
Boris Johnson das berichten zumindest
times und der Telegraph was weißt Du
darüber ist an diesem Gerüchten was dran
oder ist das wilde Spekulation
nein an diesem Gerüchten ist sicher was
dran Boris Johnson so heißt es ja
überlegt ob er seinen Hut in den Ring
wirft ob er versucht eben ein Kandidat
zu werden in der nächsten Woche es soll
ja bis Freitag entschieden werden wer
die Nachfolger antreten kann allerdings
hat das zuständige Komitee der Tories
eben festgelegt dass wer gewählt werden
will braucht die Unterstützung von
mindestens 100 Parlamentariern insgesamt
hat die Tore Partei momentan 356 das
heißt es natürlich ein unglaublich hohes
Quorum und das soll auch dazu Dean Boris
Johnson zu verhindern denn in diesem
ersten Schritt wird zwar die Fraktion
entscheiden aber in einem zweiten
Schritt wird es dann eine
Online-Abstimmung geben unter den
Mitgliedern der Tori Partei und da ist
er weiterhin sehr beliebt aber viele in
der Partei hoffen darauf das muss man so
sagen dass er eben diesen Hunderter
nicht schafft denn er hat einfach so
viel verbrannte Erde in dieser Partei
hinterlassen in seiner Regentschaft die
erst vor wenigen Minuten wo Monaten
beendet wurde als man ihn hier ja quasi
raus geprügelt hat mit mehr als 60
Rücktritten seiner kabinettsminister und
Staatssekretärin und und und das heißt
man hofft einfach darauf dass Boris
Johnson selbst wenn er in den Ring
steigt das ist noch nicht klar aber
viele glauben das dass er eben dieses
Hunderter Quorum nicht schafft und das
Boris Johnson der konservativen Partei
damit erspart bleibt
wer käme denn darüber hinaus noch in
Frage auf die Nachfolge
ja natürlich der große Favorit dürfte
Richie sunack sein der ja im leadership
Challenge im letzten also in dieser
Auswahl im Finale stand gegen List Trust
aber dann eben bei der Parteibasis sich
nicht hat durchsetzen können denn er
hatte die meisten Stimmen innerhalb der
Fraktion also innerhalb der Partei
gewonnen innerhalb des Parlaments und
man hofft viele hoffen dass er es wieder
wird weil er hat eben ökonomischen
Sachverstand so heißt es der war
natürlich auch Finanzminister das heißt
er hat sozusagen die Credentials die es
jetzt braucht um diese Situation
vielleicht in den Griff zu bekommen
zumindest ökonomisch denn der Rücktritt
von listrasse war ja hauptsächlich
geschuldet dass die Finanzmärkte
verrückt gespielt haben aufgrund ihrer
wirtschaftspolitischen Visionen und das
hat die Briten sehr sehr viel Geld
bisher gekostet und wird sie auch
weiterhin möglicherweise viel Geld
kosten insofern scheint richtig so nach
der Favorit aber es gibt auch andere
Penny Morden die ehemalige
Verteidigungsministerin der aktuelle
Verteidigungsminister Ben Wallace
vielleicht mal sehen wer es sein Ringen
den Hut schmeißen wird bis Montag ist
das möglich aber es sind dann eben
höchstens drei Kandidaten denn die drei
müssen alle über 100 Parlamentarier
hinter sich versammeln und das wird dann
ein sehr schneller Auswahlprozess eben
bis nächsten Freitag ja und bis dahin
ist auch noch sehr viel Zeit für viele
Reaktionen ich habe es gerade gemeinsam
gezeigt im im Stream die Salat Wette und
eben die Zitate die durch die sozialen
Netzwerke gehen der Salat hat gewonnen
also der Bulle war und auch viele in den
sozialen Netzwerken sie schütten Hämmer
aus was erlebst du wir reagieren die
Briten auf dieses Chaos und auf diesen
Rücktritt heute davor
also der britische Humor stirbt nie das
kann man definitiv sagen also der
Kopfsalat ist das beste Beispiel dafür
wir haben selbst gedreht am Wochenende
am Wochenende in einer in einem Ort in
dem es ein Pony gibt das zum
Ehrenbürgermeister gemacht wurde und
auch die schlagen vor das Pony könnte
vielleicht einen besseren Job machen als
listrasse also dieser Humor der stirbt
nicht aus aber man muss auch fairerweise
sagen die Beliebtheitswerte von
listrasse also die britische Bevölkerung
hat sich auch schon vor dem Chaos
gestern einen Reim darauf gemacht minus
70 das hat noch nie gegeben für einen
premier für eine Premierministerin da
gibt es durchaus Politiker die
implus-bereich landen und nur mal zum
Vergleich der einzige der noch
schlechter da steht als Liz Trust bei
minus 80 ist ein ausländischer
Staatspräsident nämlich Wladimir Putin
also die britische Bevölkerung hat da
ihr Urteil gefällt und
auch über die konservative Partei muss
man sagen denn das hat sie natürlich mit
runtergezogen deswegen gibt es auch
keine Neuwahlen das in die Tutorials wie
der Teufel das Weihwasser denn sollten
die Umfragen natürlich ein bisschen
getrieben von der Emotion des Augen ist
wirklich sich in Wahlergebnis umsetzen
dann würden hier über 500 Leber
Abgeordnete ins Parlament einziehen und
die Tories würden vielleicht bei 20 30
40 landen das heißt über 300 ihre
Abgeordnete würden ihren Job verlieren
und deswegen sind Neuwahlen im Moment
ausgeschlossen weil die Tories das
einfach nicht riskieren könnten auch
wenn dieser Ergebnisse wie gesagt eben
ein bisschen in der Stimmung des Moments
liegen Dankeschön Andreas stammen unser
Korrespondent vor Ort für die
Einschätzungen in London herzlichen dank
dir
wir bleiben in London und können jetzt
eben über diesen Aspekt sprechen mit Ben
Bradshaw von der Labour-Partei wie er
also seine Partei fordert ja Neuwahlen
haben wir im Beitrag gesehen jetzt ist
er bei uns auch in London es ehemaliger
BBC Korrespondent in Deutschland in
Berlin gewesen und jetzt eben für die
Labour-Partei als Politiker aktiv hallo
Herr Bradshaw vielen Dank erstmal für
ihre Zeit Grüße nach London
bitte schön
also es gibt gerade einen Hubschrauber
oben über mich ich konnte die Frage
nicht hören Frage habe ich auch noch
nicht gestellt ich habe es dir erstmal
nur begrüßt Frage kommt jetzt vielleicht
können Sie die ja hören wir haben sie
heute die Rücktrittserklärung von List
truckswagen genommen
es ist total chaos hier bei uns ist es
wirklich ein eine eine peinliche Periode
für Großbritannien wir machen uns
lächerlich aus Nation und der einzige
Weg aus diese Chaos meine Meinung nach
und auch der Meinung der Mehrheit der
Bevölkerung wenn man jetzt die
Meinungsumfragen hier sieht verlangen
verlangt die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung
Neuwahlen weil wir haben schon 12 Jahre
von diesem Chaos gelitten wir haben vier
drei Premierminister und vier
Finanzminister in vier Monaten gehabt
das ist unerhört das ist wie ein ein ein
ein
unentwickeltes Land und das kann nicht
so weit gehen und aber es gibt keinen
einfachen Weg zu Neuwahlen an das ist
das Problem aber ich glaube keine von
den den Menschen die
Korrespondent in seinem sehr guten
Beitrag gerade
vorgestellt haben keine von ihnen kann
die Tori Partei einigen und das ist das
Problem
gespalten seid schon vor und auch
besonders seit 13 weil sie haben sich
noch nicht einverstanden wie
Großbritannien nach brexit funktionieren
soll welche wirtschaftlichen Modell wäre
an machen sollen und das ist das ist ein
Problem was nicht losgeht mit der mit
der zurücktretung von listras aber Hand
aufs Herz was glauben sie werden diese
Neuwahlen passieren unser Korrespondent
Andreas Stamm hat auch gerade gesagt
dass die Tori Partei sich das natürlich
auch aufgrund der aktuellen Situation
sich da sehr verscheut das glauben sie
werden diese Neuwahlen überhaupt dann
stattfinden
ja es fehlt wahrscheinlich in in kurze
Zeit nicht passieren weil die
Konservativen Abgeordnete nicht dafür
wählen werden weil wie wie er euer
Korrespondent beschrieben hat von den
heutigen Meinungsumfragen wäre die
Konservator Partei total ausgerottet bei
Neuwahlen aber wenn Sie zu einem neuen
Premier mit Minister kommen
bezweifle ich sehr sehr stark dass er
oder sie die TUI Partei einigen kann für
einen äh für einen
Regierungsprogramm und das ist das
Problem der konservativen Partei sie ist
so tief gespalten vor aber besonders
nach nach brexit das meiner Meinung nach
an wenn man privat mit vielen
konservative Abgeordnete sprechen sorgen
sie auch sie sollen in die Opposition
gehen und sie sollen am außer sich
auseinandersetzen wofür sie sind die
leberpartei im Gegenteil a ist sehr
einig wir haben eine
Versicherungsprogramm schon auch für
Großbritannien wir sind sehr weit haben
am sehr große Vorsprung in den Mainz in
den Meinungsumfragen und ich glaube in
den nächsten Wochen wird der Druck von
der Bevölkerung und von den Medien in
Großbritannien für Neuwahlen so stark
dass die Konservativen nicht mehr
dagegen
resistieren können
eine user-frage die dazu passt von
Carsten no Mars er fragt wie oft dürfen
die Toristen überhaupt dann den
Premierminister tauschen bevor es
Neuwahlen geben muss gibt es da eine
Regelung oder könnt ihr das theoretisch
auch jeden Monat machen bis die
Legislaturperiode offiziell zu Ende ist
wir haben leider keine
kein Grundgesetz wie Deutschland diese
sehr gute Grundgesetz dass sie haben wir
haben ja darüber geholfen es zu
schreiben nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg wir
haben kein geschriebenes Grundgesetz wir
haben nur Tradition und die Tradition
bei uns ist das der Mensch der eine
Mehrheit im Parlament auf sich nehmen
kann
darf Premierminister sein also
es kann sein dass die Tore sich einigen
hinter jemand aber die Möglichkeit dass
diese Person dann die parte einigen kann
um ein Regierungsprogramm durchzuführen
bezweifle ich sehr und deshalb glaube
ich dass obwohl erst in zwei Jahren
zweieinhalb Jahren müssen wir Neuwahlen
haben ich glaube nicht dass diese
Regierung noch sehr lange so
überleben kann weil sie die Partei so
allergisch ist so gespalten ist und wie
die Zähne die man gestern im Parlament
gesehen haben sie hassen sich
gegenseitig die die Flügel ah der
konservativen und das ist das Problem
für für diese Partei bleiben wir noch
mal bei den Kandidaten da kommt ein
Kommentar von einem User rein von Olaf
Treder er schreibt bei Facebook Boris
kommt zurück und tatsächlich haben wir
auch gerade gehört Boris Johnson soll
wohl auch seinen Hut in den Ring werfen
bei der Nachfolge was geht ihnen dadurch
den Kopf wenn sie das hören
Boris Johnson wäre fantastisch für uns
für die Lebenszahl weil obwohl die
tutory Mitgliederschaft in immer noch
sehr mögen die die verbreitete
Bevölkerung in Großbritannien hassen ihn
jetzt er hat so viele Skandale gehabt er
hat so viel gelogen und wenn Boris
Johnson wieder an die Macht käme dann
würde würde ich ganz groß gewinnen bei
den nächsten Wahlen und auch wie er
Korrespondent gesagt hat haben die hat
die Partei das System jetzt gemacht das
ist sehr schwierig ist für Boris Johnson
mehr als 100 abstimmen zu kriegen von
seinen eigenen
Mitgliedern Impala im Parlament es gibt
einen kleinen eine kleine Rumpel von
ihnen die immer noch fanatschig für
Boris Johnson sind aber sie nicht genug
um über 100 Stimmen zu kriegen
sie haben es gerade schon angesprochen
sie sind bereit die Regierungsgeschäfte
zu übernehmen sie haben auch gesagt sie
als leberpartei sind aktuell sehr einig
jetzt ist es natürlich in solchen
chaotischen Situationen auch immer als
Opposition einfach zu sagen wir machen
das besser welche versprechen könnten
sie denn konkret liefern an die Menschen
in Großbritannien dass sie es besser
machen würden als die Tory Partei
erstens sind wir einig aus Partei und
das ist ziemlich wichtig für eine
Regierungspartei in Großbritannien
zweitens haben wir eine sehr
verantwortliche
Wirtschaftsprogramm wir sind ja weit
entfernt von dem Programm von Jeremy
Coven die für die britische Bevölkerung
viel zu extrem war wir haben eigentlich
ein Programm ziemlich ähnlich wie
Bundeskanzler Shorts in Deutschland vor
den letzten
Bundestagswahlen wir würden auch
pragmatisch wie die Beziehung zu Europa
wieder meist besser machen unsere
Wirtschaft schade nicht nur wegen
Ölpreisen und wegen
Ukraine sondern auch und und Covic
sondern auch wegen die Schwierigkeiten
im Handel zwischen Großbritannien und
und der EU und es gibt einige Sachen die
wir schon machen können um das zu
verbessern und auch das Problem in
Nordirland hat würden wir es viel
leichter finden
wie würde die Beziehung zwischen
Großbritannien und auch der EU mit der
laber-partei aussehen
es würde viel besser aussehen wie jetzt
es ist noch nicht ins Gespräch ins
Gespräch hier war das wir wieder
eintreten würden aber einige Leute
analysieren diese Chaos diese Situation
mit unserer Politik diese absolute
chaotische Situation sie sie analysieren
ist und sorgen dass es alles ist alles
mit brexit zu tun weil die die Briten
die die die die die die die am
Versprechungen die die Leute gemacht die
Politiker die für brexit waren vorher
sie waren nicht eitlich in der in der
Welt im wirtschaftlichen Modell was sie
am betreiben wollten nach brexit und das
ist das Problem und ich glaube dass
viele viele die die meines Umfragen
zeigen zum Beispiel jetzt ist eine große
Mehrheit wählen würden wieder in die EU
einzutreten das ist wahrscheinlich nicht
politisch am machbar jetzt aber ich
glaube dass die die Meinung mehr Leute
können sich sehr sehr schnell ändern
wegen dieses Chaos in wegen den Schaden
die dieses Chaos auf die Wirtschaft
erlebensstandarten und und und und
unsere
internationales Image gemacht haben und
das könnte sich sehr sehr schnell kippen
aber wenn ich sie dann auch richtig
verstehe würden sie grundsätzlich falls
Sie an die politische Macht kommen
würden Sie jetzt einen Wiedereintritt in
die EU als Labour-Partei auch nicht
ausschließen das habe ich richtig
verstanden oder
nicht bei den nächsten Wahl nein ich
werde sowieso nicht dabei sein weil ich
von der nächsten Wahl in die Rente gehe
aber nein das das ist politisch
unmachbar
aber ich kann mir vorstellen dass wenn
Label an die an der Regierung kommt bei
der nächsten Wahl das wenn wir unsere
Beziehung zu Europa verbessern wieder
und und wieder aufbauen und reparieren
und wenn die Bevölkerung sieht dass das
unsere Wirtschaft hilft und unsere
unsere unseren internationalen Ruf hilft
dann kann ich mich schon vorstellen dass
er auf längere Zeit dass wir wieder
zusammenkommen wenn nicht in in der EU
dann vielleicht in Erfde oder in der
oder in einer was die Zukunft von Europa
wie das aus entwickelt weil wir
und wir sind wir sind in geographisch in
Europa wir haben so viele gemeinsame im
Interesse gucken Sie mal in der Ukraine
wie wichtig ist es dass wir zusammen
stehen und Großbritannien steht eine
sehr wichtige Rolle dort militärisch und
das das hoffe ich und
das würde ich nicht 100%
ich habe mein Deutsch vergessen ich
würde jetzt nicht ausschließen ich würde
es nicht zu 100%
100%ig ausschließen sagt Ben Bradshaw
hier bei ZDF heute live ehemaliger BBC
Korrespondent in Deutschland und jetzt
aktiv politisch im britischen Unterhaus
für die leberparty thank you very much
danke schön für ihre Zeit und der
Hubschrauber ist immer noch da aber
danke dass wir sie hier haben
ja das Amt des Premierministers oder der
Premieren des Ministerin ist in
Großbritannien das haben wir
rausgearbeitet in den vergangenen Jahren
seit dem brexit dazu kommen auch ganz
viele Kommentare von Euch zu einem
Schleudersitz geworden und auch ihr ihr
stellt das so ein bisschen auch als
Hauptgrund für die aktuelle chaotische
Situation heraus dann gucken wir uns
doch mal ganz kurz den Verschleiß der
Tories in der Downing Street einfach mal
an seit diesem brexit da ist an erster
Stelle natürlich zu nennen David Cameron
den sehen wir jetzt er will den Austritt
aus der EU eigentlich nicht taktiert
dann mit der Abstimmung und muss 2016
gehen sein er betritt sie hier an
Theresa May sie verhandelt das dann mit
der EU den austrittsvertrag der ihr in
der Partei aber gar keine Gnade bringt
und nach ihrem Rücktritt kommt dann
Boris Johnson ins Spiel mit großen
Worten zum spektakulären Wahlsieg 2019
aber seine Taten bleiben klein im Krach
mit der EU und der corona-politik mit
seinen party-skandalen heißt es dann vor
sechs Wochen auch für ihn goodbye und
die Partei wird lässt Trust zur
Nachfolgerin aber auch sie sie scheitert
nun nach 45 Tagen
was für ein Verschleiß über den wir
jetzt weiter sprechen mit Anthony glees
in Großbritannien er ist eine der
bekanntesten Politologen und auch
Zeithistoriker erlernt und forscht an
der Universität Buckingham Herr glies
sie gelten als einer der größten Kenner
der britischen Zeitgeschichte seit dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg jetzt haben wir uns
gerade den Verschleiß angeguckt als was
wird diese Zeit Großbritanniens nach dem
brexit und als was wird diese Zeit von
Listros als Premierministerin ihrer
Meinung nach in die Geschichte eingehen
was wir sehen ist die
Normalisierung von einer
Regierungskrise oder die Normalisierung
des Staatskrise überhaupt das ist das
sehr gefährliche hier wir hören die Tore
ist wollen aus diese Krise heraussteigen
indem Sie jetzt einen vierten
Premierminister seit 2019
ernennen aber das Grundproblem wie sie
richtig erwähnt haben ist der brexit und
darüber spricht keine in der tori-partei
und wird auch sehr ungern in den
britischen Medien erörtert sie haben es
auch von meinem guten Freund Ben
bradshow gehört der der sagt viel
Richtiges über den brexit aber wenn sie
ihn gefragt haben wird Labels anders
machen hat eigentlich das
nicht nicht in einer Label Regio und das
hat verkehrstama auch gesagt aber wissen
Sie ohne
brexit richtig
anzufassen kann es keine Lösung diese
Regierungskrise und dieser parteienkrise
geht wenn man nicht darüber spricht dann
wird diese Normalisierung des Chaos eben
weitergehen und da wird es wirklich
ernst ernst für Großbritannien natürlich
aber auch ernst für die Bundesrepublik
ernste Europa denn der Westen braucht
ein starkes Großbritannien nicht ein
Großbritannien wo Chaos herrscht und ich
sollte schnell hinzufügen geschichtlich
gesehen ist das was wir heute gesehen
haben und in eigentlich in den letzten
Tagen auch seit 2016 nach der brexit war
ähnlich zu dem was in den 50er Jahren
geschah als er versucht das ging auch um
die Rolle
Großbritanniens nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg wie dieser Rolle sich in der
Welt und in Europa ausspielen sollte und
er fing an einen Krieg in Suez über den
Suezkanal
anzufangen die Amerikaner waren empört
und sagte nein das dürfte nicht machen
und das war eine große Demütigung für
Anthony Eden aber auch eine große
Demütigung für
ein England ein Großbritannien das mal
ein Weltreich hatte auf das die Sonne
nie hinunter ging und eine neue Rolle
suchte und diese Rolle könnte dann nicht
mehr als
Kolonialmacht in in Europa zu sein
meiner Meinung nach ist das was wir
jetzt sehen viel schlimmer Service denn
die
EU-Frage die brexit-frage ist nicht nur
nach außenpolitische Frage ist auch der
innenpolitische Frage also zweimal in
einem und da das Chaos das das
zerfleischt Großbritannien und die Leute
gucken so und spielen eine Rolle aber
nennen es nicht bei den Namen
ja umso besser dass sie es bei den Namen
nennen Herr glies das ist doch der
spannende Punkt bleiben wir doch dabei
Klaus Schmidt schreibt uns per Mail und
beschreibt auch aus seiner Sicht dass
das Chaos den britischen Konservativen
jetzt bei den britischen Konservativen
in dem Land eine Folge des brexit ist
jetzt haben sie und haben sie gemeinsam
gehört dass Ben Bradshaw auch gesagt hat
bei falls wir an die Macht kommen
sollten dann würden wir das auch erstmal
nicht anfassen warum spricht denn aber
niemand dann in Großbritannien darüber
weil sie sagen ist ja selbst dann kann
sich nichts lösen warum ist das so ein
großes Tabuthema
eine sehr gute Frage und ich glaube es
gibt kein Politiker vom Rang der
wirklich die Wahrheit an das britische
Volk verbreiten könnte ich meinte es
könnte vielleicht Therese may sein die
ist ganz klar machen sollte wenn man
wirtschaftliches Wachstum haben möchte
dann kann man den harten brexit nicht
haben die das geht einfach nicht und sie
sie wollte es aber nicht sagen und sie
ging Boris Johnson der wie sie gesagt
haben der redete sehr sehr groß was er
alles machen würde
Nordosten Englands und Südwesten
Englands auf dem Stand von London
bringen
Geld ausgeben Geld das gar nicht da war
und bekannt muss der Weg gehen weil er
ein Lügner war und und die die Lügen die
wirtschaftlichen Lügen gehören auch dazu
aber die wurden ziemlich gern gehört und
dann liest just und liest just versuchte
brexit durch diese wahnsinnig großer
Anleihen irgendwie als Erfolg
darzustellen in dem durch das Geld
allein Billionen Milliarden vom Pfund
sollten angelehnt werden um irgendwie
einen wirtschaftlichen Aufschwung zu
machen wir wissen alle die Finanzmärkte
haben kein Wort daran geglaubt jeder
Hausfrau jeder Ehemann weiß man wenn man
Geld braucht um das zurückzuzahlen was
man geliehen hat bedeutet das nur eines
die Pleite und wir sind bald pleite
gegangen wenn quasi Quartet und nicht so
weiter gemacht hätten wir sie wollten
dann wurde er rausgeschmissen aber immer
noch ist es so dass listras sagt sie
hätte das gemacht sie ist dies gemacht
das einzige was sie gemacht hat ist
enorme Schulden die
Generationen von Briten zurückzahlen
müssen um einen Erfolg von brexit zu
beweisen denn es ist ein Märchen dass
das ein wirtschaftliche Wachstum bringen
kann das Konto kann nur die
verschrumpfung der britischen Wirtschaft
bringen und da braucht man wirklich ein
Politiker der die Wahrheit
an das britische Volk sagt die Ahnen ist
das Volk ahntest aber sie hört es nicht
vom ihren Politikern weder von den
Tories noch von
den labour Leuten und auch eigentlich
nicht von die liberalen Demokraten alle
nur Angst dass Europa die ganze Sache so
vermockt ist dass man wie eine Pest sich
anstecken würde und das ist das
Grundproblem weswegen das Chaos
weiterlaufen meines Erachtens sollte der
König jetzt einsteigen und und sagen
einfach zu den Politikern nein Leute
jetzt haben wirklich die Briten die Nase
voll wir müssen jetzt neu machen haben
genau die thematisieren jetzt die die
Neuwahlen wir haben das rausgearbeitet
das ist wohl sehr schwierig ist es
kommen dem in unserem Chat kommen sehr
viele Fragen dazu zum Beispiel von Tom
Frank der auch sagt warum lehnen sich
denn die Briten und die Bevölkerung
nicht dagegen auf warum gehen Sie nicht
auf die Straße also Frage an Sie
vielleicht auch noch mal könnten
Neuwahlen erzwungen werden oder wenn
nicht warum nicht
die Briten gehen sehr ungerade auf die
Straße und gut so und wenn man so um die
Stadt gehen und der Nachbarn die Leute
die ins Haus kommen
Handarbeiten die Temperatur schon gesagt
die lachen und ihre Kosten denn das auch
gesagt die lachen über die Lage wo es zu
Krawatten kommt da ist es im Unterhaus
zwischen den Tores die peitschen sich
gegenseitig ich glaube die Briten können
das von selber nicht nicht machen nein
da muss der König einsteigen der ist ja
der Staatsoberhaupt das ist ja sein
Pflicht die Wahrheit an dem
Premierminister Radi Premierministerin
zu sagen und die Wahrheit ist doch ganz
klar so kann man ein Land nicht regieren
so kann man nicht weitergehen und
natürlich ist es ja mal schade dass
Königin Elisabeth die heißt Geliebte
schwierige nicht mehr da ist ich glaube
sie hätte vielleicht
wenn sie das nicht machen können dann
ist es wirklich Schluss Parlament
auflösen fangen wir vom neuen an aber
wenn ich glaube nicht dass Charles dass
das machen kann
ja natürlich meinte auch der User Tom
Frank friedliche Proteste gegen gegen
das Chaos und keine gewaltvollen
natürlich vielleicht aber doch noch mal
konkret nachgefragt bei Ihnen deshalb
ich noch nicht ganz raus gehört warum
liegt in dem System jetzt das Problem
Neuwahlen an diesem Zeitpunkt zu machen
einfache politische Frage wenn man die
Meinungsumfragen sich anschaut dann wäre
die tore-party ausradiert die hat noch
zwei Jahren wir brauchen gesetzlich
Wahlen erst im Januar 2025 also die
können dann noch zwei Jahre sitzen und
zwei Jahre lang ihre schöne
Besoldungen beziehen und und im
britischen sagen wir immer die truthahne
würden nicht für einen frühen
Weihnachten fehlen und so ist es bei
vielen MPS aber im in der tieferen Sinne
eine Regierung die ständig das Chaos
verbreitet die eine wirtschaftliche
Lösung nicht finden kann weil das
Wachstum einfach nicht da sind da ist
das muss letzten Endes die müssen
einsehen dass ohne Wahlen es nicht
weiter kann und wenn ich an Tobi
Abgeordnete sein wäre würde ich auch
sagen
den Mist den wir gemacht haben denn es
ist so groß wir sollen es der leberparty
überlassen die können es darf versuchen
irgendeine Lösung zu finden und wir die
Tore in der Opposition vielleicht sparen
wir uns wer gar nicht schlecht eine
brexit-partei und eine
christlich-demokratische Partei und so
könnte man weitergehen auch mit mit
Schottland kann das die die Lage sehr
verschärfen wenn die Tore immer noch in
Amt bleibt der Nicholas Deutschland kann
die ganze Zeit sagen
dieses wirtschaftliches Chaos die die
Todes machen in in England das soll uns
in Schottland doch
das sollen wir nicht haben das brauchen
wir nicht zu haben wenn wir unabhängig
sind also aus vielen Gründen ist das
Chaos das der Zirkus mit endlich Clowns
die alle Premierminister wollen endlich
sehen wir glaube ich dass es sehr sehr
schädlich sein wird für Großbritannien
aber nicht nur für Großbritannien
sondern für den Westen für Europa auch
für die Bundesrepublik damit haben sie
die Frage von Remmidemmi bei Youtube
auch von den Auswirkungen auf die
unabhängigkeitsbestreben von Schottland
auch beantwortet und sie haben auch die
Perspektive vielleicht zum Schluss Herr
glies angesprochen die sich auch bei uns
im Chat stellt hier wieder zum Humor
Martin Keller bei Facebook der Salatkopf
soll die Regierung übernehmen natürlich
mit einem Augenzwinkern gemeint wie es
sich auch durch den ganzen Tag in den
sozialen Netzwerken zieht und ernsthafte
Frage von Platter bei Youtube welche
Alternative wird der Bevölkerung denn
jetzt gerade vorgeschlagen
wir müssen erstmal sehen ob die Toys
wirklich einen Kandidaten finden der von
der Partei getragen wird werden kann ich
meine wie wie sie schon berichtet haben
es ich kann nicht sehen wer von den
Namen die wir kennen Boris Johnson
souela bravemann richtig Soda Penny
Moden die ja eigentlich völlig unbekannt
ist wer von diese Leute die Spaltung der
Tourist irgendwie heilen kann irgendwie
zu vereinen dieser
Partei die in endlose Fraktionen
ausgelöst ist ich sehe das einfach nicht
und wenn man das nicht sieht
und dann sieht der König das auch nicht
die Briten sehen dass ich die Briten das
sind ein dezentes Volk sie haben für den
brexit gewählt aber das was ich ihnen
versprochen worden ist
Wirtschaftswachstum und sehr viel Geld
und billiger
Lebensmittelpreise das alles ist aus
einer Lüge da jetzt da und ich glaube
die würden sagen dass der Salat der hält
sich wirklich sehr sehr schlecht und wir
müssen versuchen einen neuen Salat zu
haben die viel länger hält als
Lichtschwert die war ja doch eine
lächerliche Figur sie tut mir nicht leid
das alles was sie auf ihrem Kopf
gebracht hat sie ist selber schuld daran
sie verstand Wirtschaftspolitik nicht
sie versteht diese Sachen nicht sie kann
die Sachen sagen bitte 80.000 Tore
Mitglieder schön finden aber die
Probleme das Vereinigten Königreich zu
lösen das geht nicht die Rolle zu finden
nach brexit so wie nach so ist eine
Rolle zu finden wo wir nicht ausgelacht
werden sogar Präsident Bein macht sich
über List just hat sie über eine
das muss ein Ende ein Ende gefunden
werden und wie
das
meiner einzige Art von ist Neuwahlen ich
kenne keine andere Antwort denn es gibt
kein kein Mensch im Unterhaus der
eigentlich die Führung glaubhaft
übernehmen auch nicht schöner denn er
sagte von sich selber er sei ein
brexiter aus Prinzip also wenn man
brexiter aus Prinzip ist und von
Wirtschaftswachstum geredet dann ist man
sowieso
nichtig und und und und eigentlich
wertlos also es ist eine sehr tragische
Geschichte die 20 16 anfängt und wird
noch eine lange Zeit dauern sagt Anthony
glies hier bei ZDF heute live ganz
herzlichen Dank für ihre Einschätzungen
und auch für ihre Forderungen
Großbritannien braucht einen neuen Salat
das halten wir auf jeden Fall mal fest
dieses Zitat vielen lieben Dank Herr
Gries und Grüße nach Großbritannien
vielen Dank auch für eure Fragen für
eure Beteiligung hier bei uns im Stream
zur chaotischen Situation zur
chaotischen politischen Situation in
Großbritannien wir hoffen dass wir so
ein bisschen Überblick geben konnten und
auch eine kleine wenn auch sich drehende
Perspektive aufzeigen konnten herzlichen
Dank bis zum nächsten mal hier bei uns
und bis dahin macht's gut ciao